اقتحمت القوات الاسرائيليه صباح اليوم
مخيم عقبه جبر جنوب غرب اريحا حيث حاصرتها
بل حاصرت منزلا وطالبت في من فيه بتسليم
انفسهم الاقتحام الاسرائيلي تسبب في اصابه
فلسطيني برصاص الجيش الاسرائيلي والعشرات
بالاختناق بالغاز القوات الاسرائيليه
اعتقد سته شبان فلسطيني خلال اقتحام
المخيم وبلغ عدد الاعتقالات عشريا
الفلسطينيين الليله الماضيه في عده مناطق
بضفه غربيه والقدس
اء العربيه خالد القاسم اهلا بك خالد وهل
ما زالت عمليه الاقتحام ومحاصره المنزل
جاري حتى اللحظه
لا انتهت من وجهه نظر الجيش الاسرائيلي
الهدف من العمليه تم تحقيقه باعتقال من
تقول اسرائيل بانهم مطلوبين لاجهزه الامن
الاسرائيليه والذين تحصنوا داخل منزل في
مخيم عقبه جبر بالقرب من مدينه اريحا حيث
حصلت قوات كبيره من الجيش المنزل وكان
هناك تبادل لاطلاق النار سواء من داخل
المنزل او من محيط المنزل مع الجيش
الاسرائيلي ادى الى اصابه فلسطيني برصاصه
في الفخذ وصفت اصابته
بصفيفه الى متوسطه كما افضت العمليه الى
اعتقال سته فلسطينيين واصابه عدد اخر من
الفلسطينيين بالاختناق جراء استنشاق الغاز
المسيل للدموع نفس المشهد كان في بلده
قباطها الى الشمال من مدينه جنين جنوب
الضفه شمال الضفه الغربيه حيث عفوا مدينه
قباطيه جنوب مدينه شمال الضفه الغربيه حيث
اقتحمت قوات كبيره من الجيش الاسرائيلي
بلده قباطيه بحثا عن مطلوبين كان هناك
اشتباكات مسلحه بين الجيش ومسلحين
فلسطينيين اضافه الى مواجهات اداره في
ازقه البلده
ادت الى اعتقال عدد من الفلسطينيين كما
ذكرت احمد مجمل الاعتقالات بحسب نادي
الاسير الفلسطيني بلغت عشرين معتقلا سواء
بالضفه الغربيه او بالقدس الشرقيه لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات